[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce 7 8
weekend sur TV à 78 au programme
actualités et idée de sortie pour bien
terminer la semaine dans les Yvelines
voici le sommaire de ce 25 février
football la demi-finale de Coupe de
France Versailles 10 est programmé ce
mardi 1er mars à Nice nous sommes allés
à la rencontre des jeunes footballeurs
du club pour recueillir leurs réaction
reportage à suivre le préfet délégué
pour l'égalité des chances Raphaël
sodini va quitter les Yvelines il a été
nommé préfet du Territoire de Belfort à
côté du 7 mars prochain Patrice Karmous
l'a rencontré et puis comme tous les
vendredis nos idées de sortie pour le
weekend mais également pour les vacances
d'hiver ce sera avec Bixente Marion
Santi steban bichette qui est justement
avec nous bonjour Bixente alors comment
allez-vous ça va très bien et vous très
très bien comme tous les vendredis c'est
le weekend alors Bixente qu'est-ce que
vous nous avez concocté pour cette
émission
des vacances scolaires donc quelques
petites activités à faire comme
d'habitude par exemple une promenade
ferme on verra tout ça dans ce 7 8
weekend
[Musique]
l'actualité dans les Yvelines c'est
évidemment cette demi-finale de Coupe de
France de football entre Versailles et
Nice une rencontre programmée ce mardi
1er mars à 21h à l'Allianz Riviera de
Nice toute la ville et tout le club
vibre pour cette grande première
historique pour les Yvelines nous sommes
allés à la rencontre de jeunes du club
des images de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
un chant répété en boucle cette semaine
lors de ce stage de football à
Versailles à quelques jours de la
demi-finale historique face à Nice les
jeunes du FC Versailles 78 ne cesse de
parler des exploits de leurs aînés dans
cette Coupe de France 2022 un parcours
qu'ils ont scruté avec attention
extraordinaire surtout face à Toulouse
le but de Djoko et aussi le but de dire
à son bas contre Bergerac qui sont
passés la carte de finale 8e de finale
j'espère qu'ils vont passer à contre
Nice et qui vont gagner donc du coup je
vais supporter Versailles pour qu'il
puisse gagner je vais les encourager
de la Coupe de France des joueurs
devenus en quelques semaines leurs
idoles
il est bon
en tout cas en tous les cas dans tous
les cas c'est mon préféré de tout versa
j'ai que vu de près Vieira et
l'entraîneur
bah je leur ai fait un check et voilà
avec tous les enfants les autres enfants
ça nous ça nous fait plaisir ça me donne
du courage pour venir jusqu'à ce niveau
la N2 la Nationale 2 ou voir plus loin
encore
un rendez-vous qui me raterait pour rien
le monde
le préfet délégué pour l'égalité des
chances auprès du préfet des Yvelines
Raphaël sautini va quitter le
département il a été nommé à préfet du
Territoire de Belfort à compter du 7
mars prochain Patrice Carmouze la
rencontrer
alors j'y arrivais sans sans idée
préconçue
et j'avais une grande interrogation qui
était où en sont nos quartiers en
politique de la ville comment finalement
on en entend beaucoup parler vos
confrères en font parfois une
présentation qui n'est pas à leur
avantage
est-ce qu'ils se sont des territoires
perdus de la République
quand on arrive dans ses territoires on
se pose la question et moi j'ai été très
agréablement surpris par la résilience
de ses quartiers d'abord la résilience
des habitants qui veulent qui veulent
s'en tirer et qui aime la République et
qui aime se payer et qui veulent en être
partie intégrante
la résilience des élus locaux qui sont
vraiment tous les élus que j'ai que j'ai
rencontré tous les mères des quartiers
des territoires en politique de la ville
sont des gens qui se battent au
quotidien pour leur concitoyens et qui
donne vraiment foi en la démocratie qui
font un boulot formidable et puis
finalement les politiques publiques en
la matière sont loin d'être aussi
critiquable que je sais pas les rapports
un peu rapides de tel ou tel institution
peuvent le laisser croire la politique
de la ville ça marche
on peut faire des choses alors d'une
part on peut faire des choses évidemment
heureusement d'ailleurs sinon ce serait
désespérant si on pouvait rien faire
donc non seulement on peut faire des
choses mais en plus ce que l'on fait est
utile et ce que l'on fait alors encore
une fois les changements sont lents
qu'il s'agisse de la rénovation urbaine
ou quand on travaille sur l'éducation ou
l'emploi on transforme pas on change pas
la vie pour reprendre des expressions
politiques passées du jour au lendemain
on n'a pas de baguette magique mais
l'action que l'on mène dans ses
territoires d'abord elle est très
attendue par les habitants très reconnu
par les habitants il sont soucieux du
fait que l'on s'adresse à leur
territoire ils ont connaissent les
fragilités et très concrètement elle
améliore des choses et j'ai vu des
choses formidables dans les quartiers en
politique de la ville
je pense à deux ou trois exemples et
c'est cruel parce que je vais oublier
plein de territoire mais ce que réalise
la pmsq avec les jeunes de Trappes on
parle toujours des jeunes de Trappes
comme s'ils étaient
l'Association pour la Promotion musique
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines mais ils
prennent des jeunes de trappes et ils
les font chanter les chants chorale des
aires d'opéra et ils en font mais des
des des
enfants ont certaines vont certains vont
devenir de grands chanteurs plus tard et
ils font des spectacles mais c'est
absolument extraordinaire ça vous donne
c'est aussi beau que ce que la Maîtrise
de Radio France le maîtriser
Hauts-de-Seine enfin les grandes
maîtrise on a une maîtrise de trappe
voilà tous ceux qui disent que on chante
plus à trac voici on a une maîtrise de
trappe qui chante et qui chante
magnifiquement bien j'ai vu des actions
pour l'emploi au Mureaux ou ailleurs qui
sont qui sont remarquables donc j'ai
vraiment vu d'abord un dynamisme dans
ses quartiers une volonté de faire une
volonté de s'en tirer et
puis une volonté d'appartenir à la
République quoi je crois vraiment bien
loin des des images et je veux pas du
tout paraître le bisounours de service
mais j'ai vraiment vraiment eu ça j'ai
vu
on les connaît bien et je les passe pas
sous silence des difficultés de sécurité
dans ces quartiers des violences
urbaines des difficultés liées au trafic
de stupéfiants qui empoisonne la vie des
quartiers mais il faut pas que ces
difficultés qui sont le résultat d'une
action d'une minorité masque la réalité
de la majorité et c'est une réalité de
jeunes qui veulent s'en sortir est-ce
que c'est une expérience qui vous
servira oui c'est une expérience qui m'a
qui m'a beaucoup alors c'est toujours
difficile d'en faire le bilan au moment
où on part c'est avant les bilans sont
un peu plus longtemps après il y a
besoin de digérer une expérience mais
c'est une expérience qui me servira
d'abord j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
sur la conduite des des politiques
sociales dans notre pays puisque j'avais
pas en charge que la politique de la
ville et politique de l'emploi les
politiques d'hébergement les politiques
de logement c'est une expérience qui me
servira et puis humainement et c'est
peut-être là-dessus que c'est une
expérience a été la plus riche j'ai
appris beaucoup
de la construction d'une politique
publique locale au quotidien avec le
maire avec les habitants avec les
associations du rôle respectif que peut
jouer l'État le Conseil départemental
les associations le maire comment on
peut essayer de construire ensemble un
écosystème qui fonctionne ça je l'ai
vraiment expérimenté toucher du doigt
souvent et ça a été une très belle très
belle expérience de ce point de vue là
ça c'est des souvenirs que vous garderez
de votre fonction quel souvenirs
peut-être aussi de vos rapports avec des
élus de la population et du département
des Yvelines de manière générale moi
c'est à 7h c'est un département que j'ai
adoré je le connaissais un peu parce que
je suis né dans les Hauts-de-Seine donc
c'était le grand voisin pour moi donc
c'était pas c'est pas une terre inconnue
c'est un département que j'ai adoré j'ai
j'ai gardé certains élus
vont sont en train ou en tout cas vont
rester dans mes sont en train d'être pas
tout à fait des amis mais enfin des
connaissances que j'aurais plaisir à
revoir
j'ai que je garderai le contact avec un
certain habitant non ça a été une
expérience vraiment très riche très
formatrice
humainement
ça a été aussi une expérience à certains
égards douloureuses j'ai été on a vécu
deux attentats terrorisme pendant la
courte période dans laquelle je suis
resté dans les Yvelines l'attentat de
Rambouillet et celui de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine ça aussi ça
restera un souvenir
marquant oui c'est des choses qui ont
marqué c'est des choses qui m'ont marqué
forcément été difficile merci beaucoup
et on vous souhaite donc bonne route
vers le vers le Territoire de Belfort
merci infiniment merci infiniment
que s'est-il passé dans les Yvelines
cette semaine Célia Gates sont goût vous
propose un tour d'horizon de l'actualité
ivinoise
[Musique]
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines après
400000 injections réalisées l'un des
centres les plus importants des Yvelines
ferme ses portes un peu plus d'un an
après son ouverture il passe le relais à
la médecine de ville pour vacciner ses
habitants une convention a été signée
entre l'assurance maladie des Yvelines
et le resto du coeur dans le département
objectif de cette union permettre un
meilleur accès aux soins des
bénéficiaires 41 c'est le nombre de bus
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui roule
désormais au biométhane le dépôt de
trappe avait entamé en mai dernier sa
conversion au gaz naturel ces véhicules
en circulation constituent maintenant
une grande partie du réseau skibus le
Conseil départemental des Yvelines a
lancé son plan en prévention carence
pour venir en aide aux communes
déficitaire de logement sociaux la ville
du Pecq est la première en bénéficié
avec l'inauguration d'une résidence de
90 habitations une opération qui permet
à la commune de se rapprocher de
l'objectif des 25 % de logement sociaux
obligatoires fixé par l'État le cirque
Nicolas Zavatta a fini par
WBA continental elle a battu la
championne d'Europe des poils lors du
gala de boxe organisé par le club bam
l'héritage aux Mureaux
l'actualité de la semaine c'est aussi la
guerre en Ukraine les Russes ont
bombardés plusieurs villes du pays
notamment la commune de Lille la Chambre
d'Agriculture d'Île-de-France collabore
avec cette ville ukrainienne et détails
dans cette interview express du
président de la Chambre d'agriculture
d'Ile-de-France
[Musique]
la Chambre d'Agriculture est jumelée
depuis maintenant 6 ans ou 7 ans avec la
chambre de le vivre en Ukraine ville
austro-hongroise à l'origine
c'est-à-dire que et aller c'est une
ville qui est à 70 km à peu près de la
frontière polonaise
[Musique]
et Jean sont complètement perdus même à
vivre qui est à 70 km de la frontière
ukrainienne ils ont pris un bombardement
en fait sur une base aérienne qui est à
40 km de ville donc même elle vive en
tant que tel ils ont entendu les
déflagrations et cetera il y a un état
d'urgence qui a été décrété c'est-à-dire
que les enfants n'ont plus d'école et
les salariés ne peuvent plus aller au
travail ce qui pose que d'ailleurs dans
les exploitations des soucis majeurs
puisque en fait vous avez bon nombre
d'exploitation qui ont des animaux et
donc les chats d'exploitation sont
obligés de faire le tour des salariés
pour leur demander quand même devenir au
travail pour pouvoir nourrir les animaux
aujourd'hui le premier objectif je pense
qu'il est humain avant tout c'est-à-dire
c'est de mettre les gens à en fait de ce
qui peut se passer là-bas
personnellement je vais accueillir
probablement des amis Ukrainiens chez
moi donc on est en train de voir pour
les faire sortir du crâne actuellement
et j'ai pris contact hier avec le
président du conseil départemental des
Yvelines pour voir dans quelle mesure on
pouvait accueillir quelques femmes et
enfants de de de du secteur de vive
sachant que les hommes souhaitent rester
sur place pour se battre moi mon
homologue qui est président de la
Chambre d'Agriculture de le vivre qu'à
62 ans lui souhaite se battre à 62 ans
il souhaite prendre les armes en fait
pour défendre son pays
comme tous les vendredis j'ai votre
rubrique légale checking avec le
collectif Les surligneurs aujourd'hui
ils reviennent sur les nominations au
Conseil constitutionnel à regarder
en vue du prochain nouvellement du
Conseil constitutionnel de nom on
suscité une vague de critique
premièrement la proposition de données
Véronique Malbec est qualifié par
beaucoup de conflits d'intérêt dans la
mesure où l'intéresser lorsqu'elle était
procureur général aurait poussé au
classement sans suite de l'enquête
préliminaire concernant Richard Ferrand
dans l'affaire des mutuelles de Bretagne
or juridiquement le conflit d'intérêt
est une situation qui résulte de
l'existence au sein d'une même personne
ou autorité de deux liens d'intérêt
contradictoires et que cette même
personne autorité prend une décision
affectant l'un de ces deux liens or ici
la situation est différente puisque le
président de l'Assemblée nationale
lorsqu'il nomme un conseiller
constitutionnel agit en tant qu'autorité
purement politique donc en droit il n'y
a ni
parce que non juriste de formation c'est
vrai et c'est peut-être une aberration
mais aujourd'hui aucun texte n'exige de
compétences juridiques spécifiques pour
occuper le poste cela en fait est dû en
grande partie au fait que le Conseil
constitutionnel est avant tout un
organisme politique chargé notamment
d'assurer les fonctions
juridictionnelles alors cela étant le
Conseil dispose un service juridique et
au fait composer notamment de magistrats
fonction et justement de préparer
l'analyse juridique des décisions liées
au contrôle de constitutionnalité des
lois il est donc pas nécessaire que tous
les membres du conseil soit des juristes
chevronnés non le vrai problème c'est
que pour respecter le principe d'un
parcalité madame Gouraud sera tenu de se
déporter sur un nombre significatif de
dossiers mais en vérité c'est déjà le
cas pour les membres actuels du conseil
constitue un acte purement politique qui
échappe à tout contrôle du juge et ce
dans le respect du principe de
séparation des pouvoirs alors une
solution existe en appeler à l'éthique
ou mieux à la sagesse des parlementaires
qui ont la possibilité de voter contre
ses propositions et de forcer les
autorités concernées à proposer d'autres
noms chiche
ce matin l'heure de sortir dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
on retrouve Bixente mérians anti
Stéphane sur ce plateau alors Bixente
c'est quoi c'est quoi le programme
Michael Gregory
à mon arc avant de recevoir mon invité
pour une petite sortie en extérieur je
vous propose en cas de jour de pluie par
exemple une activité bien couverte bien
au chaud un escape game avec Justine
Brazier journaliste aussi de TV 78 nous
sommes allés en essai 2 dans le coin
dixit à Poissy engrenage Versailles
petite découverte de ces deux escape
game
[Musique]
le concept c'est assez simple les tables
réduire le nombre de prisonniers à
petite peine en priorité ils ont dit
qu'ils allaient mettre à l'épreuve dans
une prison dans les enfermant mais en
leur laissant une chance de s'échapper
si ils font preuve de cohésion de
solidarité et d'un peu de logique ils
ont une chance de s'échapper en moins de
60 minutes de la prison
on a choisi en fait de faire des salles
à peu près du même niveau qu'on appelle
de niveau intermédiaire on est un peu
près sur du sur du 50 % de réussite sur
sur toutes nos sacs on trouve que c'est
le c'est le mieux pour les joueurs parce
que les joueurs aguerris bah ils
trouvent pas ça trop simple 50 % est
quand même un groupe sur deux qui
arrivent pas au moins d'une heure et les
groupes débutants ils arrivent quand
même à se débrouiller il y en a qui
peuvent réussir alors que c'est la
première escalier
[Musique]
le Game Master il va jauger ses indices
en fonction de l'avancée des joueurs en
fait il va avoir deux buts le premier
c'est d'intervenir le moins possible
pour que l'expérience appartiennent au
joueur et qu'il se débrouille le plus
possible par eux-mêmes ils y prendre en
plus de plaisir mais il va être aussi là
pour débloquer pour pas rester 20
minutes sur une énigme sinon bah les
joueurs vont s'ennuyer tu as pas
d'intérêt donc c'est façon son rôle et
fondamental parce que c'est lui qui
donne le rythme au jeu
donc on est quelques années en arrière
en 1679 tout simplement et donc à cette
époque il y a des empoisonnements à la
cour de Versailles donc le roi Louis XIV
est affaibli son pouvoir royal est
affaibli donc il va demander à Louis de
La réni qui est un lieutenant général de
police d'enquêter sur cette sur cette
affaire on a fait les scénarios on a
fait les énigmes par nous-même et puis
au niveau des décors on a travaillé en
fait avec des des professionnels du
théâtre qui ont fait ou des chars par
exemple sur Eurodisney choses comme ça
on en a fait deux qui sont un peu plus
difficile que les autres qui sont donc
sortir ou mourir et Tchernobyl on
communique pas trop sur le taux de
réussite l'idée pour nous c'est que on
va aider un peu plus un groupe qui est
un peu plus en difficulté forcément et
puis laisser un peu plus se débrouiller
les meilleurs
[Musique]
il faut de la fouille il faut de la
logique il faut de la réflexion etc mais
plus important c'est comme on arrive
forcément une équipe contre 3 et 6
joueurs chez nous à partir du moment où
on a un élément faut que toute l'équipe
soit au courant et donc l'idée c'est à
la fois que tout le monde soit courant
sans se parler tous par-dessus des uns
les autres moi je vais commencer à faire
les bougies donc la communication
générale c'est la voilà la première
qualité donc 50 % des réussites pour ces
de ça les d'ailleurs sur les deux que
nous avons fait nous en avons réussi
qu'une je dirais pas laquelle Michael
bon alors c'est déjà pas mal hein
Bixente alors moi je suis vraiment un
piètre joueur d'escape game j'aurais
même pas réussi à faire 50 % mais bon
faut pas vous dégrader comme ça je suis
juste réaliste alors tout autre sujet à
présent cette semaine à Bixente pour les
jours de beau temps on peut aller à la
ferme par exemple et oui le temps serait
un peu réchauffer ces derniers jours
alors pendant les vacances une petite
journée au ferme de Galice ça fait du
bien pour en parler avec nous nous
recevons Bruno Gansel responsable
communication des fermes de Gali bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
centre de Gally dans les Yvelines c'est
à Saint-Cyr à Sartrouville plein de
choses sont à découvrir on va commencer
par exemple à Saint-Cyr c'est 4 hectares
de ferme au milieu de chevaux lapin
chèvre les vacances commencent bien pour
vous la première semaine c'est bien
déroulé on a la chance d'avoir le temps
avec nous et donc pour les activités qui
se passent en extérieur c'est top comme
vous le disiez il y a des grands espaces
avec des prairies les animaux sont là et
broutis font caresser par les enfants on
a également un grand bois dans lequel il
y a il y a plein d'ateliers à faire
autour des petites bêtes autour des
animaux qui a qu'on trouve dans les bois
franciliens donc il y a effectivement
plein de choses il y a également des
ateliers à faire en intérieur
si on vient à 17h30 par exemple on peut
assister à
un message des animaux
accompagner l'animateur et puis qui va
s'occuper en fin de journée des animaux
être sûr qu'ils ont bien mangé et
s'occuper des litières et tout ça et
donc les enfants peuvent regarder cette
activité quand il fait beau on a dit
c'est
bien évidemment puisque il y a des
grands il y a des grands bâtiments il y
a pas mal d'atelier qui se déroulent en
intérieur on va pouvoir faire du beurre
suivant les jours on va pouvoir faire
donc du beurre je l'ai dit du pain il y
a plein d'ateliers à venir faire le pain
et étant l'atelier qui qui est le plus
demandé il est disponible trois fois
dans la journée donc il y a pas de souci
on peut accueillir pas mal d'enfants
même les jours de pluie
à partir de 3 ans à partir de 3 ans on
peut commencer à leur faire faire des
ateliers mais sinon en terme de visite
libre même plus petit pourra rentrer
dans le parc au chèvres on a plein de
petites chèvres naines et donc les
enfants oui à partir de 2 3 ans
accompagné de leurs parents peuvent
venir caresser ses animaux et c'est
génial c'est un moment de découverte
super sympa à faire en famille pour
réserver ses ateliers donc c'est sur
votre site internet les fermes de
galip.com est-ce qu'il y a un événement
spécial pendant les vacances à ne pas
manquer non j'allais dire il y a
l'atelier l'atelier pain qui a lieu à
trois reprises tous les jours tous les
jours tous les jours et puis après sur
le sur le site internet vous verrez
chaque jour il y a un atelier à 15h30
dans la thématique change donc si on
veut venir plusieurs fois on peut venir
plusieurs fois et faire des ateliers
différents
il y a quelques heures une nouveauté du
printemps 2022 des nouvelles sers sur
gouttière pour les fraisiers exactement
c'est une c'est la première fois cette
année qu'on a planté des fraises sitôt
dans l'année sous des tunnels plastiques
ce qui va créer un petit micro climat
est-ce qu'il va nous permettre d'avoir
des des fraises en primeur si tout se
passe bien fin avril début mai des
fraises cultivées en Île-de-France super
goûteuse donc c'est la première fois
qu'on fait ça et on vous tiendra au
courant parce que on mise beaucoup
là-dessus
les récoltes pour les autres récoltes ça
sera
on va commencer à partir de voilà le
mois d'avril au mois de mai généralement
il y a les premiers légumes qui vont
arriver avec les premiers salades les
premiers navets et donc cette année on
veut proposer une offre de de fruits
gourmand avec des fraises et puis il y
aura bien sûr les tulipes qui est une
des premières écoles de laine alors
certes ça se mange pas mais c'est super
joli il y en a toutes les formes de
toutes les couleurs merci Bruno Gansel
d'avoir été avec nous et rendez-vous
tout au long des vacances aux ferme de
Gally pour toutes ces activités à faire
et il y en a tant en fait finalement on
pourrait se dire on peut venir presque
tous les jours exactement vous êtes les
bienvenus merci à vous nos conseils
d'être venu en cette émission à Bixente
alors après une bonne journée à la ferme
rassurez-nous il voit quand même de
l'énergie pour faire la fête du coq à
l'âne en effet mais depuis ce mercredi
16 février les boîtes de nuit sont
ouvertes après un escape game entre amis
ou comme vous avez dit une balade à la
ferme petit décrassage pour danser toute
la nuit si vous avez encore de l'énergie
à condition d'être majeur et vacciné
bien sûr on vous a préparé un petit top
des établissements yvelinois du monde de
la nuit regarder
[Musique]
on passe maintenant au traditionnelle
agenda venir la semaine prochaine oui
Michael comme vous venez remplacer
Grégory canalet mon binôme habituel je
veux vous rendre hommage en tant que
présentateur sportif de la chaîne une
petite je vais revenir
à Nice bien sûr mardi prochain c'est le
grand jour la demi-finale de Coupe de
France que nous attendons tous entre
l'OGC Nice et le FC Versailles 78 coup
d'envoi à 21h si vous êtes courageux et
que vous avez fait le déplacement sur
place à l'alliance Riviera de Nice tant
mieux pour vous mais à défaut d'avoir
fait la route dans le sud vous pourrez
bien entendu suivre la rencontre dans de
nombreux bars yvelinois ou chez vous si
vous avez la chaîne payante bien sûr en
tout cas nous à TV 78 on vous donne
rendez-vous pour une belle émission
spéciale avant la rencontre combien de
temps Michael c'est 2h avant la
rencontre
à 19h un très gros programme nous attend
alors dans cette édition spéciale nous
aurons des invités des reportages joueur
interview avec le directeur général
Jean-Luc Arribart et puis on enchaînera
de 20h à 21h pour l'avant match avec nos
chroniqueurs dans si on parlait sport
l'émission
aussi au départ du Paris - Nice cette
année le top départ de la prestigieuse
course cycliste et donner à
Mantes-la-Ville première étape à suivre
à partir de 12h50 boulevard Salengro
pour une arrivée sur ce même boulevard
aux alentours de 17h sur la place la
ville de Mantes a prévu un village
d'animation tout le weekend de 10h à 18h
des ateliers vélo des chaux de VTT des
animations pour les enfants aussi comme
un stand de maquillage des structures
gonflables ou un manège le jour de la
course des écrans géants diffuseront la
course en direct et le Paris-Nice
restera dans les Yvelines le lendemain
puisque la seconde étape partira à
dauphingie merci Bixente pour toutes ces
idées de sortie alors c'est déjà la fin
de cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
un très bon weekend sur TV 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]